خرافه تدفع كاسيميرو لكتابه اسمه بشكل
خاطئ مشجع وفرهامبتون يسخرون من مدرب
ليفربول وماذا تعني احتفاليه راشفورد
الجديده هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على
العربيه رياضه بمتابعتكم
كشف البرازيلي كاسيميرو لاعب ريال مدريد
السابق ومانشستر يونايتد الحالي عن كتابه
اسمه بحرف خاطئ طيله مسيرته كاسيميرو اوضح
في موقع فوتبول فوكس بان اسمه الحقيقي هو
كارلوس هنريكي كاسيميرو وكاسيميرو بحرفي
اي وليست اي القصه بدات عندما كان
كاسيميروفيساو باولو وقامت الاداره بكتابه
اسمه خطا ولان المباراه كانت الاولى في
مسيرته واستطاعت التميز فيها فضل كاسيميرو
الابقاء على الخطا كنوع من التفاؤل به حتى
يتابع مسيرته الكرويه بشكل مميز وهو ما تم
حتى اللحظه والله اعلم
سخر مشجع ولفرهامبتون من تصريحات الالماني
يورجن كلوب مدرب ليفربول بعد الفوز على
ثلاثيات النظيفه في الدوري الانجليزي
البرتغالي روبن نيفيز نجم ولفرهامبتن احرز
الهدف الثالث لفريقه من هجمه مرتده خرج
بعد الهزيمه واكد ان هذا الهدف بالتحديد
غير محسوب بالنسبه له هذا التصريح اشعل
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ليرد عليه
بتغريده اشار فيها الانتهاء اللقاء بهدفين
دون رد وليس بثلاثيه وصوره لوجه عابس هذه
التغريده حصلت على مشاهده اكثر من تسعه
ملايين متابع ونالت اكثر من
138 الف اعجاب
من منا لم يشاهد طريقه احتفال ماركوس
راشفورد لاعب مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزيه
الجديده بدايه العام الحالي والمتمثله
بجروه نحو احد الزوايا والوقوف بثبات
والاشاره باصبع السبابه الى راسه التقارير
الصحفي الصحفيه تسابقت في التخمين حول
مغزاها بعد رفض اللاعب الدولي الانجليزي
الكشف عن معناها التوقعات جميعها اتجهت
صوب الصحه العقليه منهم من اشار اليها
باغلاق راشفورد لعقله امام الضوضاء
الخارجيه والبقاء في حاله تركيز تام
واخرون اكدوا ارتباطها بالنقد غير المرغوب
فيه الشيء الوحيد المؤكد هنا ان هذه
الاحتفاليه اصبحت ترندن داخل وخارج المعجب
الاخضر بعدما شهدناها مع ساكا لاعب ارسنال
وكمش لاعب بايرن ميونخ وفي الكره الصفراء
عبر لاعب التنس نوباك تيكوفيتش وظهرت
فيليك ايضا عبر اللعب ارتشر
الختام مع خبر انتزاع ايليشا لمن لاعب كره
لاعبه كره القدم لصداره ترتيب اللاعبين
السويسريين الاكثر متابعه عبر الانستقرام
من اسطوره التناسل وتعد هذه هي المره
الاولى من نوعها في سويسرا منذ ظهور منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي التي يتفوق فيها رياضي
على حيث باتت لاعبه استون فيلا الشهيره
تملك احد عشر مليونه ونصف المليون متابع
عبر الانستقرام وبفارق يصل لاكثر من 200
الف متابع اعتذر